There are a number of challenges
associated with supporting a Windows
environment in a large enterprise. There
might be hundreds or thousands of
devices. You have an IT team that needs
to be able to install, update, and
manage all of these Windows devices
wherever they might be in the
organization. We also have security
concerns, especially with mobile devices
where there may be important and
sensitive data on those devices, but we
need to be sure that we're able to
secure all of that information wherever
these mobile devices might be. We also
have to set rights and permissions for
any local file shares that people may be
accessing. And of course, if someone has
a laptop, that information can be picked
up and moved anywhere that laptop might
go. So whether you're working on a big
spreadsheet or you're watching a movie
on your computer, there are a number of
different features included with Windows
that can help you regardless of what
you're
doing. In a business, all of your
systems are probably documented in a
central database called the active
directory domain services database. This
is a very large database that contains
everything about every component that is
connected to your network, including
individual usernames, their permissions,
information about security features, and
anything else that may be connected to
your infrastructure. Having all of these
servers and printers and laptops and
user accounts in one database allows for
central management of all of this
information. This allows organizations
to scale up their computing platforms
and be able to manage all of these very
different devices. You'll also find that
Active Directory is one that is a
distributed database, so you can have
multiple versions of the Active
Directory database located in different
parts of your network. This provides
scalability and redundancy for all of
this important information that keeps
your network running. This is probably
why you often don't see Active Directory
being used in a home environment since
usually we only have a handful of user
accounts and passwords that we need to
keep up with. So if you are logging on
to your corporate network, you're
authenticating to the VPN or you're
simply accessing a share across the
network, you're probably doing this
based on information contained within
the Active Directory domain services
database.
On your home network, it's still
possible to logically group together
devices. We refer to this as a Windows
workg groupoup. Instead of managing
everything from a central database like
you do with Active Directory, a Windows
workg groupoup manages each individual
device as a single unit. But on your
work network, you're using a Windows
domain. With Active Directory,
everything is centralized. All of your
authentication is contained within one
single database and you're able to
support those thousands of devices from
this one Active Directory
infrastructure. Depending on where we
are, we might want to customize some of
the features available on a laptop or a
desktop that we use on our Windows
network. If you're at work, there's
usually a standard desktop. It has a
very specific user interface and it
might have a very limited amount of
customization. You might not be able to
change the background. You might not be
able to modify the language settings
that are available. And you might not
even be able to install or remove any of
the software on that device. But this
does make all of these systems easier to
manage because they all have a very
similar user interface. And it also
means that you could sit down at any
computer and be able to immediately
understand where all of the important
resources might be. At home, of course,
we don't have these restrictions and we
might want to customize our computing
platform to be specific to us. We might
want to change the background and the
colors we use. We can change the type
faces and the size of the fonts on the
screen. And we can really customize the
device to be something that we use in
our personal home
environment. If you've ever worked in a
corporate help desk, then you're
probably familiar with remote desktop.
This is a way that you can remotely
connect to a computer and be able to see
and interact with a desktop that's on a
different computer. This means that you
can sit in your chair and interact with
any of the Windows devices that are on
your corporate network wherever they
might be. To be able to connect to these
remote devices, we need a client that's
able to provide that functionality. We
refer to this as the remote desktop
protocol client or the RDP client. The
client is the software that connects to
a remote desktop service. This client
software is available on many different
operating systems and many different
platforms. There are RDP clients
available for Windows, Mac OS, Linux,
Android, iOS, and almost any other
platform. The software that is running
on that remote device that allows us to
connect with our remote desktop client
is the remote desktop service. This is a
service that's available in Windows 10
Pro and Enterprise and Windows 11 Pro
and Enterprise. If that remote desktop
service is running on that remote
computer, then we can connect to that
computer using a remote desktop client.
You'll notice that this remote desktop
service is not available in Windows 10
home or Windows 11 home. That's because
in a home environment, you don't need
that remote desktop functionality. you
can simply walk to the other room if you
need to provide any support for that
Windows
computer. There's also a difference in
the amount of memory that is supported
across different Windows editions.
You'll notice for Windows 10 and Windows
11 Home, we have 128 GB of memory that
is supported in the 64-bit version of
that software. If you're running the
32-bit version of Windows Home, then
you're only running Windows 10 because
Windows 11 Home does not have a 32-bit
version. But Windows 10 Home does have a
32-bit version and it supports up to 4
GB of memory. Since 4 GB of memory is
the maximum amount that you can support
in a 32-bit version of Windows, that
same amount is included for Windows 10
Home, Windows 10 Pro, and Windows 10
Enterprise as the maximum amount of
memory that's supported. If you're
running the 64-bit version of Windows 10
and Windows 11 Pro, you can support up
to 2 terabt of memory. And if you're
running the 64-bit version of Windows 10
and Windows 11 Enterprise, you can
support up to 6 TB of
RAM. We mentioned earlier how important
it is to keep data safe on your mobile
devices, your laptops, your desktops,
and anything else that you're using at
home and at work. The technologies that
allow us to apply encryption to the
information that we're saving on these
storage devices is Bit Locker and EFS.
EFS is the encrypting file system and
it's part of the NTFS file system that
could run on your Windows 10 or Windows
11 systems. EFS allows you to select
individual files or individual folders
on your system and the operating system
will encrypt all of the data that you
store on those resources. Bit Locker
takes a much broader approach to
encryption. This is full disk encryption
or FDE. This means that everything on a
drive will be encrypted, including the
operating system, your data files, and
anything else that's stored on that
volume. This means if someone does get
access to your mobile device or to your
laptop, they can pull the drive out of
that system, but they'll have no idea
how to view any of the information on
that drive because everything has been
encrypted with Bit Locker. You'll find
that there's use for both EFS and Bit
Locker for both business and home use.
And you'll find functionalities for both
of these technologies available in all
of these Windows
editions. We also mentioned that at
work, you're able to manage thousands of
systems from one central place. The way
that you're able to do this is through
the group policy editor. This is part of
Active Directory and it allows you to
set policies of how systems can be used
on your network. If you're managing a
single device without active directory,
then you can simply use a local group
policy and you can open the group policy
editor by using
gpedit.msc. But at work, you probably
have a large active directory
infrastructure and you would use the
group policy management console or
gpmc.msc that will allow you to set all
of the policies for all of your systems
across the entire enterprise.